i started i couldn't breathe actors get
a bad rap for being considered divas
over saying no but when the simplest of
shots can affect your career or image
sometimes you gotta do what you gotta do
we're taking a look at 20 times actors
refused to film a scene i don't know
what it is but i want to try it number
one you can't just have a nude scene for
the sake of having a nude scene if you
can tell the same story with your
clothes on then that's the way it should
be done minka kelly and euphoria refused
to shoot a nude scene on her very first
day on set sam levinson had planned for
kelly's character to be nude in a moment
where alexa demi unzips her dress kelly
said i'd love to do this scene but i
think we can keep my dress on sam didn't
hesitate to accommodate the request and
kelly said that he shot a beautiful
scene and got exactly what he wanted
number two it's a love story baby just
say no to intimacy the reunion scene
between henry cavills geralt and anja
chalotra's jennifer in season two of the
witcher was intended to be a lot
steamier until cavill had his say he
admitted we wanted it to be emotional
rather than sexual it was really really
important and we had to lean away from
what was originally on the page the
result of this choice brought siri into
the equation more giving the three
characters a chance to bond
number three if actors can still have
their clothes on after intimate scenes
there are very few excuses for nudity on
tv
sydney sweeney never took a second
thought to challenge the shirtless
scenes sam levinson would write into the
script if she found it unnecessary she'd
say something and sam would immediately
accept it it seems to be a general rule
that nudity is okay with the cast but
only if it serves a purpose sweeney had
said of the situation i've never felt
like sam has pushed it on me or was
trying to get a nude scene into an hbo
show when i didn't want to do it he
didn't make me
number four don't give a mouse a cookie
and don't give julia garner a mouse
garner who plays ruth langmore in ozark
is petrified of mice no matter how hard
she tried she just couldn't touch one
not even a fake mouse the crew ended up
needing to bring in a hand model for one
shot because there was no way she was
touching one even thinking about it just
makes me cringe she admitted to not
being able to breathe because of it and
people kept sending her pictures of mice
for a month after that cruel and unusual
punishment
number 5 we're team cat on this one
while most of the euphoria cast are
quick to praise sam levinson's behavior
and attitude barbie ferreira may be of
another mindset after getting into an
argument with levinson over the
direction her character was taking in
season 2 she supposedly walked offset
which prompted cuts to the script she's
noticeably in far less of the show in
this season and she also didn't attend
the premiere which fueled the rumors
number six for the sake of the show
let's hope this relationship is
repairable
allegedly season two of euphoria needed
to be rewritten because hunter shafer
and jacob allorty refused to act
together this is a huge shift from where
they were at in season one the two have
since unfollowed each other on social
media and wiped any pre-existing photos
of the two together they were pretty
much inseparable during the filming of
season one going to events together and
showering each other with praise here's
hoping they can work it out
number seven sometimes taking a leap of
faith is not the answer kirsten dunst
grew up around strong female figures who
gave her a great sense of what she is
and isn't comfortable with doing saying
if my intuition's telling me no no no
then i'm not going to do it it's truly
admirable she recalled during her time
shooting spider-man that they kept at
her about one stunt where they strung
her to the top of the ceiling and had
her bungee jump she didn't want to do it
but she tried it once nobody had the
cameras rolling when she did and so she
stated clearly well you should have shot
that because i'm never doing it again
you'll have to find another way
number eight rampage ended on a happier
note thanks to dwayne rocking the boat
dwayne the rock johnson is pretty
opposed to sad endings in movies because
real life can be sad enough so when they
wanted george the gorilla to sacrifice
himself for the sake of mankind it was
almost enough for the rock to quit the
project
number nine shawarma makes for good last
words in the avengers after iron man
crashed into the ground at the end of
the movie he was supposed to say what's
next but robert downey jr wasn't a huge
fan of the line and felt there was a
snappier way to end the movie he managed
to convince joss whedon to let him try
something and that's how we ended up
with the iconic line about shawarma you
ever tried shawarma that bit was so
beloved kevin feige wanted to get the
gang back together for a fun end credit
scene and the only time that was
possible was the night of the premiere
and that's how we wound up with this
perfect setup for a joke a bunch of
superheroes walk into a shawarma joint
and the first hero says to the next can
you come up with a punchline leave it in
the comments
number 10. hemsworth was tired of being
the muscle he wanted to make people
laugh too while rdj was beloved from the
start chris hemsworth shined in the
third thor installation and that was
because he did not want to play the
straight man in a marvel film again
taika ytt supported his wishes and that
is why ragnarok became one of the best
movies in the franchise
number 11. prince wasn't afraid of
purple reigning all over the kardashian
parade prince had no interest in meeting
them he'd requested to be in an episode
of new girl it was by far one of the
best episodes in the show and the plot
completely revolved around a party he
was throwing he noticed that khloe
kardashian and kris jenner were on the
invite list in the script and wasn't too
happy about it he'd stated that the two
would never be invited to a prince party
imagine being a kardashian going about
your kardashian life and hearing this
years later we almost feel bad
number 12. there's no shame in not
wanting to take a walk of shame there
was a lot of uproar about lena heady not
being present for her walk of shame nude
scene in game of thrones to be fair she
loved the character and was more than
willing but she was pregnant at the time
and chose not to we're just picturing
die hard fans with little bells chanting
shame
shame
number 13. this one could be a great
get-rich-quick scheme
it's no secret that allison hannigan
didn't like kissing her co-star jason
siegel comparing kissing him to kissing
an ashtray but did you know it went even
further than that she convinced him to
pay her 10 bucks for every cigarette he
smoked he owed her 200 bucks after day
one which was enough to get him to quit
cold turkey at least for a bit he
started up again after the stress kicked
in but alison's repulsion very likely
led to far fewer intimate scenes between
the two on the show number 14. imagine
knowing the real story when riverdale
first came out you'd be infuriated the
big riverdale season 3 cliffhanger was
never even meant to be a cliffhanger you
know the one where jughead's hat was
burned in the fire cole sprouse wasn't
present in the scene because it was just
too darn cold for him he was like i
don't want to do it so he didn't
number
for a man playing an indestructible
character he sure did hurt himself bad
ryan reynolds didn't really do any of
his stunts on deadpool because the guy
was injured once upon a time he learned
months after filming safehouse that he'd
fractured vertebrae in his neck that
ended his stunt career real quick
reynolds had said i remember the doctor
sitting in the office it was about the
seventh time i had been there that year
and he writes on a prescription pad rips
off the note and it reads stunt man
point taken no stunt is worth your life
number 16 adopting may very well have
saved sandra bullock's life she stopped
doing stunts after adopting her son in
2010. she didn't want to be reckless
with him in mind questioning what if i
should fall and die on this one would it
be a smart move
number 17 zombies can't be killed with
concrete it's fine after suffering a
serious injury on the set of santa
clarita diet drew barrymore refused to
do any more stunts of her own she was
supposed to leap onto the back of a man
from six feet up but wound up hitting
her head on the concrete floor she
suffered a serious concussion but
luckily that was the worst of it when it
first happened the show creator feared
for the worst she returned to set a week
later but the effects of the concussion
lingered
number 18 threesomes don't seem like
they lead to good storytelling julia
robert's niece emma roberts dropped out
of spring breakers after learning her
character would be part of a threesome
the role ended up going to ashley benson
and the scene was done by her james
franco and vanessa hudgins in the end
number 19 shakira got gazelle looking a
little less skinny and a little curvier
and that's
solving hollywood's problem in zootopia
gazelle is a pretty tiny character so
it's hard to imagine that there was a
time she was even skinnier shakira was
adamant gazelle have some meat on her
bones which resulted in the gazelle
being a bit curvier but that's still an
overstatement
number 20. honestly this one's kind of
wholesome which is why we included it
kirk cameron refused to kiss his co-star
or even touch her too much in the movie
fireproof they ended up bringing in his
wife to do the intimate scenes with him
it worked out in his favor that his wife
looked enough like his co-star that they
could pull it off but that wouldn't work
in every situation
well that's 20. your body is your
instrument why put that instrument
through danger and risk losing your
career or your life
did any of these stories surprise you
let us know in the comments and thanks
for hanging out with us here at the
things